all right gisele season five is finally
here we had to wait a minute for it but
it was worth the wait
how are you feeling i'm feeling great it
is a great
season fantastic our best ever it's very
dramatic so dramatic
when was the last time you were happy so
unless i'm with you
i can't be happy i want to start with
where you are at
as we start the season you and jamal
back together giving it another shot
um how did you two come to the decision
that it was time to give it another shot
you know i've been asked that question a
couple times there was no like
all of a sudden green light there was
nothing that was like blaring
it was just um i guess a feeling and we
just felt like it was time
and we're still rocking and rolling
i was gonna say are you still together
today yeah
end of july 2020 okay yes even the
pandemic because with the pandemic it
makes it hard because you can't see each
other as much
um you know he lives in atlanta so it's
been rough but
we're still rocking and rolling some of
your cast members
in the premiere kind of question the
fact that you two are back together
because
when we flash back to season one jamal
was a cheetah cheater
pumpkin eater he loved to hide his
salami
how did you um reconcile all that
i guess you know over time bill's
trust and i felt like it was time to
leave the past in the past you have to
keep in mind that
when at our first season we had been
divorced like 10 years
so of course the ladies are gonna have
things to say
of course but you know you know i don't
care
you do not care
in that same line there is speculation
that you two got together just to like
for like clout for you know to have
something to do
what do you say to people who are
skeptics of the fact that you two got
back together
i feel like that's weird i feel like
that
is i mean it'd be one thing if
um he wasn't the father of all of my
children but he is
he's always been in my life um clouds if
i was gonna get
with somebody for clout his name would
probably be idris elba
or jay-z or you know someone like that
right not like my clients are you know
with me and your dad yeah your kids
believe that
my dad isn't trustworthy it was
surprising to hear
your daughter's view of your
in jamal's relationship yeah and that
they're kind of frustrated by the fact
that you two got back together
what was it like to hear that from them
um
well that's that's never fun but you
know they've never known us to be
together because when we got divorced
they were babies
so this is new and i get it how do they
feel about him now
it's one day at a time it is you know
their dad is their dad so that's
really what matters and really what's
important it's sad to hear that they
think he calls them just to
then call you to say like i checked in
on the girls the word
untrustworthy is thrown around so how do
you
navigate the conversations with them
about who you think your dad is is not
who i think your dad is
right and we've had um very open and
honest conversations really because they
can read a bunch of stuff on the
internet about their dad and about me
and about our past so there's never like
secrecy or lies or anything that i want
them to
be confused about i want us to have open
dialogue
um and i also have to keep in mind that
teenagers
so they have their view from a teenage
perspective
and that is totally fine i am i am
more than um understanding of where they
come from
they're very protective of their mom as
they should be
do you see marriage again with him i
don't know
um that's like the million-dollar
question i mean definitely i
am rooted to this area for a little
while my kids are in high school i would
not
move them around right now so we'll see
i mean if
if the situation presents itself and if
it's at the right time then absolutely
would he ever move back to dmv area
would he be the one to
the move probably not i mean he does
have a very big job
um you know he passes to church in
atlanta it's a huge church
and he's very happy there he's loving
what he's doing so probably
not so i guess whenever bravo fires me
then i'll put atlanta
don't put that out in the universe no
they might not they they could keep you
around there is you know a whole show in
atlanta that you know
those girls yes there is an entire show
in atlanta and those ladies are fabulous
do you want to be a first lady again
because that's also
getting married again is that job title
comes back
um you know i haven't really thought
about that however
you know i do know what that entails
i've done that before
um it's a big job and a big
responsibility so
i don't know we'll see what the future
brings okay
let's move on to what's going down with
the group heading into this season
a lot of you feel a certain type of way
about candace it seems
candice understands that she's extremely
annoying
and um she's a very opinionated
and and to the point where most of the
time we don't want to hear it
um and candace sometimes doesn't
understand that in order for there to be
a conversation she's got to stop
talking um so
we're just a little frustrated in the
beginning of the season
with her mouth it doesn't stop you have
to pick and choose your reads
you can't just go on a reed frenzy you
gotta pick and choose
it seems like the biggest candice issue
is going to be
the much reported on altercation between
candace and monique
can you tease at all what leads them to
that moment
they were definitely having issues
within their relationship we've seen
their
relationship go from best of friends
um besties to having some issues
to um an altercation that
was truly shocking and
didn't need to go there at all
were they both in the wrong is somebody
in the right there
um were they both in the wrong
absolutely not
so you know i do want the viewers to see
and
kind of give their opinion on on who's
right and who's wrong
but i don't feel like they were both
wrong no
not at all okay the trailer kind of
hints to maybe who you believe to be in
the wrong because
you karen and robin have what appears to
be a come to jesus moment
with monique after that yes
we never thought as black women we would
be right here but we are
it's not something you can brush under
the rug but you've got to address this
we have been able to hold ourselves
above
the stereotype and in five minutes
she took it away it definitely needed to
happen you know what
happened was nothing that we ever
thought
we would see on this show and on this
platform so
the kind of the beauty about what
happened if there is anything beautiful
about it is it allowed
us to really have deep conversations and
true conversations about how we feel
how we feel we're portraying ourselves
to the world and
what we're okay with and what we're not
okay with um
and we can all see with what's going on
with black lives matter
and the change in the culture that
black women are viewed a certain way
and i never want to be
in a situation as far as platform is
concerned to be viewed in a way
that is animalistic or violent
you guys have never shied away from
having those conversations on the show
you visit a plantation
you've spoken openly about colorism
within the black community
but do you see with this larger social
movement happening in the world
that affecting what kind of
conversations and what kind of things
you guys bring to the show moving
forward
oh absolutely i think it br it opens the
door for us to have
um real conversations all the time which
is what we've been wanting to do i think
that um now is the time for
more than ever so because we are
educated we're black we are um
we're smart we're sassy we're fun and
we're funny
doesn't mean that we can't have those
real
deep-rooted conversations which will
help
our viewers it allows our viewers to
have conversations with their
girlfriends
and really break barriers and make some
changes
definitely i want to do a little moment
of that right now uh because i do think
it helps
viewers to learn what their kind of tv
friends have gone through
in terms of racism to make it real and
grounded
do you have either your first experience
with it the first memory you have that
racism existed or
a moment that really sticks out to you
that kind of changed you
yeah um you know i'm
originally i'm from dc i'm from the dc
area when i grew up in dc
dc was majority black so i never had
any incidents where a white person was
saying something that was very
bothersome to me
until i went to college i went to
hampton university and hampton is a very
white town with a big black college
sitting in the middle of it
and so when i was with my friends from
school
and we were in the city um
for no reason like a group of white men
just walked up
to us and started calling us the n word
for no reason
and i remember feeling
internally infuriated and that was the
first time that i was internally like
burning with fire infuriated and just
wanted to lash out
um and that i remember that day like it
was yesterday
so going from that day to me being now
being a mother
and things happening happening to my
children
it's even more of a feeling of
wanting to fight and wanting to
make changes immediately so that my
children don't have to
continuously have racial things
happen to them so we've got a lot of
work to do
what kind of stuff are your are your
girls going through well they've had
some incidents in school
um you know they one time my my uh
one of the twins went to school and she
had the n-word written on her desk
my oldest went to high school and she
was treated by some of her white friends
well they weren't really friends you
know they informed her that because
she's around
they they feel like they need to like
hide their belongings because she might
steal it
because she's black and
you know it's i want to say that's
subtle but it's not subtle
like that's in your face racism and
we just need to do better we got to do
better it this shouldn't be happening
anymore
all right i want to take it back to uh
that conversation we
see between you and monique um you
seemingly tell her you don't want to be
around her
after that did i really say that
i by no means wants to be
near you and maybe i don't need to be a
part of this anymore
okay fine i said what i said but you
know
i i don't ever not want to be around
people
based off of the things that they do but
i do want to have a conversation about
what you do
okay because i feel like there's a lot
of speculation that monique was done
with this group that she was quitting
being around you guys that she was done
really
that was those were the headlines that's
an interesting take what you just said
though
yeah so um is that a question
i just want to get you see your response
you know what monique does with regards
to the show is on monique um
i don't hire people i don't fire people
so i don't know
whether or not she's done with us i do
know that she likes to scratch my face
out on pictures
and you know this face is way too pretty
for all of that
i mean we are grown women we are above
scratching our faces
on pictures i would think this group
does have a new face in it though dr
wendy
how do you feel about dr wendy i
actually love dr
wendy um wendy lets everybody know she's
got about 18 000 degrees
and oh and i have five with it because
you know what she is extremely smart
and fun and witty and i love
i love a woman who just speaks her mind
and can back it up
and i think we're gonna see that judging
by the trailer when she tells ashley to
come correct dr wendy address me
correctly
sweetie in the premiere is karen has
quite the snippy comment about
i've known wendy she sits on the same
boards as me we're in the same groups
and
unimpressed so far yes but karen we're
still unimpressed with you
honey so it's fine yeah what can you
tease at all what we're gonna see
between you and karen because you you
know that you two
are one of the best duos in housewife
history
but it's a it's a
it is a wine yeah yeah it's it's ups and
downs
ins and outs um and you will see more of
that season five
um i'm trying to think if we had any
we didn't have any mime moments between
me and karen
thank god whoa up gizelle i'm just
saying oh my god camera time
it's very irritating okay but can you
move on
this is some [ __ ] who are you
but we we have some moments okay well i
hope there's something that's on the
level of the mind moment because
that is just history at this point
it is that i didn't know in the moment
that that was gonna live with us forever
but
uh that was actually hilarious
all right anything else we need to know
about season five that you're excited
for us to see
scared for the audience to see um i'm
super excited about our trip
i think the viewers will love the trip i
i love
the journey that and juan take
this season i think it's beautiful and
magical and i learned so much more about
their relationship this season than i
ever have and i've known robin forever
um and you know i i i'm curious to see
how how the viewers um take ashley
because ashley's
whole story goes on a roller coaster too
i mean now she's a new mom
um and you know she's got some issues
there with mr michael of course this is
like
it we ended up going back to a hotel
so i you know we we have a lot to unpack
in season five it's like deja vu deja vu
on deja vu
not really well we had some twists
because you know
ashley might not be reacting the same
way that she has in the past
so we'll see
you